good morning everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP were going
to be studying today is SCP 2662
object class Keter special containment
procedures containment of SCP 2662 is
primarily focused on preventing
unauthorized entry to its containment
unit for this purpose on site task force
Town 9 belligerents bodyguards has been
organized to guard SCP 26 62 s
containment unit and keep track of new
religious followings focusing on the
worship of a CP 2662 task force tau 9 is
in the following stricken from the
document to use non-lethal methods when
dealing with an attempt of authorized
entry authorized to use lethal force if
necessary all members of Task Force tau
9 are to be tested by annually or
kognito hazardous influence as
containment of SCP 2662 is completely
voluntary
it is currently contained in an enlarged
humanoid containment unit with standard
safety measures for low-risk humanoids
as detailed in document zero nine nine
eight - ka
additionally SCP 2662 is allowed one
copy of a daily newspaper of its choice
a computer and requested computer games
totaling no more than 50 US dollars
every month description SCP 2662
is a Cognito hazardous entity
approximately 4 meters in height and 200
kilograms in weight SCP 2662 appears to
be in a vaguely humanoid shape with
approximately 20 additional muscular
Hydra stats in similar structure to
cephalopod limbs attached to its back
these limbs are fully functional and
allow SCP 2662 to perform up to 10
from tasks at once SCP 2662 s primary
anomalous effect only occurs after
long-term repeated exposure usually
being in the same room as or interacting
daily with SCP 2662 subjects exposed to
SCP 2662 for a period of six months or
longer are at risk of becoming acutely
aware of SCP 2662 s wants or needs and
are compelled to fulfill them they may
also suffer from quasi psychotic
episodes when under stress SCP 2662 is
unable to affect humans that have a two
or higher ma RS by defecting resistance
scale score SCP 2662 secondary anomalous
effect is the spontaneous generation of
religious followings at an approximate
rate of at least once a month this
generation is involuntary and causes SCP
2662 notable distress religious groups
generated by SCP 2662 usually focused on
attempting to break into its containment
unit in order to perform various rituals
that are violent and/or sexual in nature
these groups tend to be highly organized
and appear to adapt to each failed
attempt despite there being generally no
contact between different generated
religious followings the following is an
incomplete log of incidents relating to
SCP 2662 a full list can be found in
document 26 62 - one incident 26 62 - 7
on 2003 our religious group known as
towards him successfully broke into SCP
26 62 s containment
22:50 SCP 26 62 is seen taking a shower
in preparation for sleep there is a loud
noise as previously undiscovered
explosives are dead
and underneath the center of SCP 2662 s
containment unit 22:51 five injured
civilians climb out of the hole left by
the detonation SCP 2662 leaves the
shower to investigate the noise 22:52
agents and notify task force tau 9 of a
breach into containment they attempt to
suppress the initial five civilians
unsuccessfully as five more arrive with
weapons
22:56 after a brief struggle agent and
are pinned down and tied with rope by
the civilians the injured civilians
approach SCP 2662
the uninjured civilians stab their hands
with knives masturbate and then draw
unknown symbols on the walls with a
mixture of sexual fluids and blood
22:58 SCP 2662 says oh man come on
that's really not sanitary or necessary
SCP 2662 appears to gag upon witnessing
the symbols the injured civilians
successfully corner SCP 2662 in the
shower stall 22:59
the injured civilians are seen squeezing
blood out of their wounds and rubbing it
on to SCP 2662 while singing SCP 2662
says jesus christ stop please I just
took a shower
20300 task force tau 9 arrived to SCP
2662 s containment unit task force tau 9
managed to suppress all civilians
successfully and proceeded to move SCP
2662 to a temporary unit until repairs
can be completed incident 2662 - 13
2005 a religious group known as the
betrothed successfully broke into a CP
2662 s containment 822 SCP 2662 is seen
eating breakfast and reading a newspaper
824 security officers stationed at SCP
2662 s containment unit enter with a
researcher the researcher can be seen
carrying a piglet 8:25 sav 2662 says can
I help you 826 researcher says all our
Lord please accept this innocent
suckling swine freshly orphaned from
slaughter of both mother and father may
its sole of loss fuel you researcher
proceeds to castrate the piglet in front
of SCP 2662 and place the testes on SCP
2662 s food 8:28 SCP 2662 says no thanks
I'm full go home your Lord is pleased
with the offering task force tau 9 is
notified of a breach into containment
829 SCP 2662 attempts to read its
newspaper researcher
slits the pigs neck and throws it onto
the table blood splatters the newspaper
8:30 SCP 2662 says i what
look can you go read a Bible or
something you really really need it a CP
2662 puts the newspaper down the
accompanying security officers execute
researcher by a gunshot to the head then
they begin consuming her 8:32 CP 2662
leaves the scene to vomit in a toilet
8:34 task force tau 9 arrived to move
SCP 2662 to a temporary containment unit
and detained the guards after further
investigation all involved personnel
were civilians policing his personnel it
is unknown as to the whereabouts of the
actual researcher and security officers
incident 2662 - 78 2014 an unnamed a
religious group consisting of d-class
personnel and two members of Task Force
tau 9 successfully broke into SCP 2662 s
containment SCP 2662 was redesignated as
Keter upon further review of incident
2662 - 78 407 SCP 2662 can be seen
sleeping in its bed for 10 the entirety
of Task Force Town 9 is called for an
off-site mission against orders Task
Force tau 9 chooses to leave four of its
members behind to keep watch on SCP 2662
4:15 - of the remaining members tackle
and lock the other two in an unused
containment unit 4:20 a cargo truck
arrives on site or SCP 2662 is being
kept for 25
the two remaining members unload the
cargo of d-class personnel they lead the
d-class personnel the task force town
nines armory 430 the d-class and
remaining members arm themselves from
the armory it break into SCP 26 62 s
containment unit 431 SCP 2662 is roused
several d-class personnel guard the exit
to the containment unit as well as the
corresponding hallway SCP 2662 says Oh
what are we moving I'm not scheduled
until next week 4:35 agent in the two
remaining available members of task
force town 9 begin undressing the
d-class personnel that are not guarding
for 36 SCP 2662 attempts to alert task
force Town 9 to no response for 37 agent
in begin carving symbols into the
buttocks and thighs of they undressed
the class personnel the d-class
personnel begin to engage in group sex
after being carved
439 SCP 2662 says what the [ __ ]
seriously now
look seriously can you go find another
god I hear Buddhism is all the rape
d-class nine nine three zero four
attempts to pull SCP 2662 into the group
SCP 2662 responds by saying the [ __ ]
stop seriously
Lord commands you and all that stuff to
cut this [ __ ] out 4:40 all d-class
personnel currently engaged in sex
ceased their movements they all turned
to stare at SCP 2662 task force Town 9
arrived at the off-site meeting point
only to be told no such mission exists
task force Town 9 begin moving back to
site 441 SCP 2662 says oh thank god I
can control you guys now kinda maturity
is happening right on time good to know
okay tell me what the [ __ ] is going on
here 4:42 agent says after the blood
birthing ritual we are going to take you
to your sacred chambers where we our
families and our lineage will remain in
service for you for all eternity
the people here caved you with us you
may go where you please 445 SCP 2662
responds by saying you must be kidding I
can leave whenever I want I just have to
ask
besides I the d-class personnel begin to
continue engaging in group sex SCP 2662
says seriously stop
you're all [ __ ] disgusting I'm not
even ready to settle down with a call
yet I'm only like 200 years old I'm
barely legal 446 agent says do you
really think the foundation will let you
go if you ask well you can certainly ask
you'll be sorely disappointed my lord
for 48 SCP 662 says yeah well it turns
out to be the case I can just wait until
I'm strong enough to break out in the
meantime I'm going to sit in the
bathroom and wait the rest of you can do
your stupid blood orgy SCP 2662
moves to the shower stall and turns on
the water it sits in the shower stall
for the remainder of the incident
okay that about does it for today thank
you all very much for listening and you
are all dismissed goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bessette Desmond Hoskins and
gets a berry thank you all very much for
your support is greatly appreciated
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well go to
patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you